the first high-heeled ever was a piece
of military Footwear
people in West Asia had been tremendous
horse riders and that's how they fought
they rode in the saddle and they stood
up to shoot their bows and that meant
you need a heel to keep you in the
stirrups nice and stable the char of
Persia
he's called Abbas the first he sends off
some emissaries into Europe and they
turn up wearing high heels and everyone
goes whoo so suddenly this military
clothing becomes adopted in Europe
but it's a little bit later on in the
early 1600s that we start to see eels
coming in and it starts with the blokes
it's for being manly and butch but what
happens quite quickly is women start to
emulate male fashion and part of that is
they start wearing men's shoes the real
big moment is when Louie xiv of france
starts wearing heels because he's quite
a small man and he famously has red
heels
that's Louboutin mirrored later on in
the 20th century suddenly everyone in
the court is wearing heels heels go
through a bit of an up-and-down history
and a 1700 the lot of us are talking
about the rationalism of men by contrast
women are said to be emotional and
sentimental and can't be trusted to do
important things like think and so men
are being advised to wear rational shoes
and high heels not rational the 1860s
this is when women's heels starts become
sexy we have photography the brand new
technology and quite often in
pornography of this period you're seeing
women still wearing their boots their
shoes with the heels on so it becomes
erotic
Hollywood had a huge influence on the
rise of Hills as a symbol of sexiness in
the 1950s Marilyn Monroe famously quoted
company B exact words but she said you
know we owe the man who invented high
heels so much and she was speaking on
behalf of women from Monroe who's about
glamour and beauty and sexiness
she felt that that was an asset
[Music]
who can tell whether women are wearing
high heels without actually seeing their
feet so it is that posture change in the
gate but a more recent study has shown
that actually it's the change in the
shape of the spine that is actually the
attractive thing
we looked at all the research on high
heels and they are not healthy hey there
was increased risk of musculoskeletal
conditions bunions and pain
[Music]
[Music]
I think there - I kind of kept too much
part of aesthetics and imagery in
history and power and sex to ever go
away and I think they'll always be there
I'd rather get recited pain and wear
them and look nice for it I think I'm
crazy about that I think we all know and
I think any smart well one would go on
where anything irrespective or what the
consequences are
thanks for watching don't forget to
subscribe and click the bail to receive
notifications for new videos see you
again soon